Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu k w unsere kleine welt.
Die mittlerweile fünfte ausgabe erwartet euch ich bin's tim bedarf und heute geht's mal nicht
um brexit nein das thema ist zwar noch lange nicht abgeschlossen also wieder der brexit,
dass ich das hier behandeln möchte aber bevor es dann mal weitergeht wollte ich mal so ein bisschen meine monat thematische ausrichtung ein wenig erweitern
bleibt aber in gewisser hinsicht in der spur weil ich mir irgendwie so dachte,
eigentlich gar nicht so uninteressant bestimmte komplexe dinge die sich permanent in der welt,
abspielen zu verfolgen und vielleicht auch immer mal wieder zu besuchen wenn sich was nennenswertes getan hat,
also vieles leidet ja so da drunter dass man immer.
Entweder gibst du tagesziel klos alle berichten darüber und kaum ist es so ein bisschen weniger interessant ist es irgendwie komplett verpufft und ein so ein thema.
Sicherlich nicht das einzige was hier noch auf der liste steht aber ein thema ist die situation in und um,
hongkong herum wo es ja viele proteste gegeben hat da kriegt man immer wieder was mit wenn viele stühle fliegen dann sind die kameras an und wenn es vorbei ist dann
eben nicht mehr so und lange rede kurzer sinn ich habe mir jemand eingeladen nämlich den mario mario six aus hallo mario.
Moin genau weil mit dir wollte ich erstmal bequatschen und warum,
weil du bist so ein hobby hongkong geworden habe ich so mitbekommen.
Seit ein paar jahren schon ne warum eigentlich also wie kam das.
Ich war das erste mal zweitausendelf in in hongkong ganz normal wie das als tourist vierzehn tage ein bisschen rumgelaufen paar fotos gemacht und als ich dann weggeflogen bin hab ich mir gedacht da muss ich nochmal hin,
hallo hongkong wir sind noch nicht miteinander fertig.
Und so wurde das dann quasi regelmäßig also ich versuche seitdem immer wenn ich so 'ne längere schreibt phase habe also wenn ich ein drehbuch schreibe oder irgendwas was was längere schreib arbeit,
erfordert dass in hongkong zu machen,
weil ich festgestellt habe dass das für mich hervorragend funktioniert das in so einer wimmer liegen stadt zu machen also und hongkong ist halt eigentlich so dass das das musterbeispiel einer willigen statt.
Und dann gucke ich immer dass ich so zwei monate manchmal drei da bin und vor mich hin schreibe.
Und ansonsten mich durch die stadt treiben lassen.
Du bist ja eigentlich was sie was sind deine aktuelle selbst beschreibung eigentlich würdest du das sagen.
Dankeschön.
Autor okay gut.
Nein ich schreibe drehbücher fürs fernsehen ab jetzt in wildberg geschrieben der läuft am zweiten elften im zdf samstag zwanzig uhr fünfzehn also ein krimi.
Und ansonsten bereite ich gerade einen neuen neuartigen spielfilm vor den ich äh nächstes jahr drehen werde der wird dann auch im zdf laufen.
Das wo ich also das wird ein film wo ich ein buch und regie mache.
Und der wird hi parlament heißen also eher so mit.
Sein und ansonsten schreib habe ich jetzt gerade ein buch geschrieben warum warum an die zukunft denken erschienen im duden verlag kann man kaufen bei amazon und sonst wo.
Und ja also schreibe viel machen viele filme und.
Genau und vor allem bisher auch so so wie wie wie ich auch so ein bisschen so ein,
so ein alter social media hase blogger szene und so weiter hat uns ja alles mal zusammengetrieben also die diese früh digitalen wesen die man nicht,
gestanden haben warum die anderen im internet nichts anfangen können und ich denke gewisser sich teilen wir da auch so einige einige grund ansichten was so
das leben in der digitalen welt betrifft aber das soll heute eigentlich gar nicht so das thema sein da können wir uns vielleicht ein anderes mal,
noch ein bisschen ausgiebiger mit machen aber nicht unerwähnt lassen sollte man wahrscheinlich dann vielleicht bekanntestes projekt elektrische reporter in den fand ich ja schon,
stil bildet und wegweisend eigentlich in vielerlei hinsicht nicht nur nicht nur weil ich da auch zwei mal erwähnt wurde aber,
einfach einfach weil es so ein schönes so eine schöne verknüpfung von so retro stil und zukunft in einem war so ja das.
Ja wer das nicht kennt das habe ich fast zehn jahre gemacht auf dem zdf auf zdf info also aufm,
spaten sparten kanal und das war als es alles anfing glaube ich,
schon die einzige sendung die sich gezielt mit mit dem netz und mit social media mit dem ganzen sozialen phänomen des netzes,
also keine computer sendung war und irgendwie erzählt hat was ist der beste trainer oder so,
sondern eigentlich sich dafür interessiert hat wie verändert das netz unsere welt.
Und dann können wir vielleicht dann auch wieder diesen bogen eigentlich zum thema so so dein stick ist so ein bisschen außer content berühre kultur also was
was was was macht eigentlich grade so die welt worüber denkt sie nach womit beschäftigt sie sich oder was was was prägt sie eigentlich grade und hongkong ist halt so ein bisschen so ein ort,
über den ich jetzt noch wenig weiß.
Ja das hilft mir eh gleich alles aber äh aber was ich weiß ist was ja auch vollkommen klar ist es ist so eine dieser,
hotspots auf diesem planeten wo dinge fundamental
anders gespielt werden so gibt sicherlich auch noch andere orte letzten jahren ist zum beispiel auch so dubai auch so ein so ein ort gewesen auf einmal alles hin stürmen wo unheimlich viel entsteht irgendwie eine unglaubliche thermik auch,
steht wo sicherlich auch viel verbrannt verschenkt und geopfert wird aber
so globale auswirkungen haben so vielleicht nach dem intro müssen denke ich erstmal so ein bisschen zurück,
blättern dass man mal so ein bisschen versteht was es eigentlich so mit hong kong auf sich hat was glaube ich jeder so ein bisschen weiß ist ja ist irgendwie china aber nicht so ganz so
haben sich die briten irgendwann mal dein nagel gerissen und irgendwann mussten sie's wieder hergeben und seitdem wird ungemütlich dass.
Ja das war das war so die twitter fassung.
Genau was passiert das jetzt noch ein zweihundertachtzig zeichen gepasst hat etwa ne.
Machen wir mal warum man fred draus der anfang von von hongkong ist wirklich sensationell die geschichte ist super es und zwar,
ist großbritannien,
in seiner,
das war zur viktorianischen zeit und damals.
Fuhren schon viele handels schiffe von großbritannien nach asien und handeln so vor sich hin
und es begann dann mit der mit der feststellung eines außenhandel defizit das heißt die
briten stellten fest so wir kaufen ganz viel kram es von den von den chinesen seide und weihrauch,
gewürze und was man halt so alles einkaufen kein schild,
die chinesen waren überhaupt nicht für uns kaufen das interessiert die überhaupt nicht was wir haben das ist blöd,
wann haben sie gar nichts ne also.
Was hätten sie denn gehabt also maschinen.
Ja weiß ich auch nicht irgendwie aber die chinesen haben sich irgendwie nicht interessiert was was die briten haben und das
führte dann halt so zu so einer wirtschaftlichen schieflage und das wollten wir nicht so auf sich sitzen lassen haben sie hin und her überlegt dann haben wir gesagt ok,
wir haben doch noch aus indien indien war ja damals auch politisch gucken wir mal ob ob die vielleicht irgendwas haben,
und dann haben die briten tatsächlich aus aus indien opi um geholt und das nach nach china,
importiert und quasi den o p um handel also alles was man so kennt,
höhle blase chinesische dings und so düsterer chinesisches gemäuer und dann liegen die leute halb ohnmächtig da und qualmen vor sich hin das war eine britische erfindung
britische zivilisation eigentlich.
Weil der klatsch moin ja eigentlich mehr so aus afghanistan und diesen gegen den kam oder zum,
die kultur des anbau s soweit verstanden wurde um.
Aber das war tatsächlich ein export export produkt der briten für den chinesischen markt damit haben die geld verdienen,
also die haben die waren drogen hinter dem harte doping harte drogen harte drogen verkauft das fanden die chinesen überhaupt nicht toll tatsächlich,
hat sich das natürlich auf die gesellschaft ausgewirkt dass die leute irgendwie op zum rauchen ganz toll fanden und dann irgendwie so ein bisschen an,
antriebslos in der ecke hängen statt zu arbeiten beispielsweise oder sich um ihre familie zu können.
Und so kam es zum krieg das ist tatsächlich so das heißt der der sogenannte opi um krieg war quasi ein abwehr krieg von china gegen die drogen gegen den drogenhandel,
gegen die klans die kriminellen clans gehoben klar aus großbritannien und diesen krieg haben die briten dann gewonnen weil sie einfach die besseren schiffe und die besseren waffen hatten.
Als kriegs beute haben sie dann die.
Das war der erste op.
Das war der erste op im krieg und man sagt zwar geschichte wiederholt nicht tut sie aber doch ein paar jahre später hatte ich das,
wirklich nahezu eins zu eins wiederholt also da haben die china wieder gesagt jetzt hört mal auf mit eurer op frei und
dieses haus ist trading korporation bla hat gesagt so wir verkaufen was wir wollen,
könnte uns mal wir sind briten.
Und dann gab es wieder im krieg und dann haben wir wieder die briten diesen krieg gewonnen und es kriegst beute haben sie dann diesen die land zunge bekommen,
oder gönnt sich genommen die der insel hongkong gegenüber lag halt kolumne.
Genau das ist dieses dieses dieses,
der insel gegenüber und um dann um jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen vor zu spulen wie es überhaupt ist im ganzen.
Gebiet hongkong kam ich glaube das war dann fünfzig jahre später dann hatten die briten halt die insel,
und diese land zunge irgendwie voll gebaut und brauchen mehr land und dann pachten sie für für neunundneunzig jahre dieses gebiet was heute noch new new territorium es heißt,
das war tatsächlich dazu gepachtet das finde ich ganz interessant weil da merkt man dann dass es dann doch irgendwie so ganz,
ganz okay das verhältnis eigentlich gab zwischen den briten und ich hätte nicht gelesen ja stinke finger zeigen können haben sie gesagt okay dann parte das mal gibt.
So kriegen wir schon irgendwie hin aber das waren halt auch,
zeiten wo krieg führen und irgendwie insel erobern und so okay warte so unter ländern so ging man miteinander oben.
Ja euer land hatte,
noch also die paar insel weil dann irgendwie auch egal ne.
Genau und hongkong war auch hongkong war auch damals nichts wertvolles ne das muss man auch sehen dass es ich glaube es lebten damals siebentausend,
menschen auf der ganzen insel und die meisten im im westen wo das heutige bedienen,
ist das das waren so ein paar zwei.
So fischerei dörfchen und dann gab es im süden,
wo das heutige stanley ist so eine art säubern lässt sag ich jetzt mal also das war irgendwie so,
süd asiatische piraten die da unterschlupf hatten das war alles und die briten haben sich dann erstmal in dem heutigen niedergelassen.
Da fand es aber nicht so toll was.
Und dann sind sie in das heutige scheu das ist im nordwesten er gezogen.
Und äh ja haben denn da victoria city gegründet damals hieß ja alles viktoria,
heute eigentlich auch nochmal kommt ist es ganz kompliziert sich in,
hongkong zurecht zu finden weil alles irgendwie queen und victoria heißt queen street queens queens irgendwas und dann nochmal das gleiche mit victoria,
und ab und zu gibt's auch nochmal klingt aber das sind so also das häufigste ist eigentlich immer victoria alles ist dieses riesen areal wasser areal.
Zwischen colour,
und der insel hongkong heißt auch victoria haber das ist der das ist der hafen also dieses das wasser stück zwischen zwischen insel und festland es nennt sich alles hafen und das war auch mal hafen,
und dann somit rutschen wir schon die geschichte etwas weiter das interessante an.
Hongkong ist eigentlich dass es die ganze stadt ein einziger hafen war dass der der einzige sinn und zweck dieser stadt.
War diesen hafen am laufen zu halten.
Weil das quasi das einfallstor der briten für asien war.
Die haben da ihre station aufgeschlagen gesagt so hier bleiben wir und alles was irgendwie trading abgeht ne mit,
mit indien und sonst wo das lief dann äh das lief dann über hongkong,
und das war die hatten halt auch irgendwelche freihandelszone frei frag mich nicht,
irgendwelche verlockenden konditionen sodass es ganz schnell einen welthandel handels hafen wurde und das merkt man hongkong heute noch an also hongkong hat.
Als stadt keiner oder als als quasi land ist ein kleines land eigentlich keine,
eigene geschichte,
in ganz hongkong findet man keine statue von irgendeinem geritten feld her der mal glorreiche schlachten geschlagen hat für für hongkong und.
Weil es einfach nur so 'n kleines fischerdorf war.
Falls es es war es war früher in fischerdorf und dann war es ein hafen ein die ganze stadt war ein einziger hafen ein riesengroßer hafen,
und deswegen gibt's halt auch keine,
weil die briten halt auch kein interesse hatten an sowas wir hatten halt ihre ihre kleinen garnison und ihre ihre wellen sich da auf dem berg gebaut.
Aber ansonsten gab es zum beispiel auch keine alleen also bis heute findest du da keine,
keine plätze so als europäer vermisst man das so ein bisschen dann gehst du durch die gegend und denkst jetzt könnte eigentlich nur so ein platz kommen,
mit dem springbrunnen drauf oder nein kommt nicht ne geht einfach einfach straße an straße an straße.
Was ja auch so ein typisches ding ist in asien und wir müssen eindruck das also einfach.
Ja ja aber es gibt halt auch nicht viel.
Stellung stadtplanung so gar nicht stattfindet.
Aber peking zum beispiel hat dann irgendwie den kaiser palast auf den läuft alles zu oder so ne das hat hongkong halt auch nicht,
es gibt halt auch auch keine ebenso was keine paläste oder oder schlösser oder sonst was es gibt diese,
diese willen die damals die briten gebaut haben die.
Eigentlich am am hang oder tatsächlich oben auf dem berg victoria peak ne wie heißt der berg victoria.
Weil da auch das klima so ein bisschen angenehmer war.
Und aber ansonsten ist es halt das ist die ganze stadt eigentlich ein einziges unternehmen weil was denn dazu kam.
Irgendwann war halt die diese finanz.
Metropolen geschichte also das das ist halt die die banker statt von von ganz asien wurde,
das war so der zweite aspekt einfach weil es halt auch eine steuerlich und und in sachen zoll.
Sehr interessant war wohl dann finanzunternehmen aufzumachen deswegen da also die innenstadt center.
Also ich ich glaub auf der ganzen insel hongkong gibt's halt mehr als dreihundert hochhäusern das und die sind wirklich hoch navigieren das ernst wenn die hochhaus sagen die beiden nicht irgendwie,
marzahn also hongkong center ist so ein bisschen so wie ich mir.
Ich mir new york vorgestellt hat ne ich mein die vorgestellt hab ist tatsächlich teilweise unglaubliche meiner steht und die und diese.
Links und rechts gehen diese diese glas und metall türme wirklich ins nicht und man hat.
Die haben irgendwie einen abstand von von einer gasse haben sie doch sogar gas dazwischen freigelassen zwischen zwei riesen dinger das ist schon ziemlich unglaublich.
Was was behandeln jetzt das was dich bei diesem besuch so gefangen hat also dass du sagst,
da muss ich jetzt noch mal hin das
nicht nur gewesen sein oh ein land ohne geschichte was eine kultur im wesentlichen von den drogenhändlern aus großbritannien injiziert bekommen hat das ist ja sagen wir mal für sich jetzt erstmal,
noch keine geschichte muss ja dann,
irgendwas anderes sich dort entwickelt haben auf dieser basis was so dein ist es halt weil es so ein ding groß wir sind anders andere regeln.
Es ist tatsächlich wenn man wenn man so aus europa aus europa kommt.
Es ist wirklich eine sehr sehr andere geschichte weil das spektrum sehr viel breiter ist also erstmal dass das sozial das finanziell des wirtschaftlichen spektrum der der bewohner da laufen leute rum,
sind so unfassbar unfassbar reich ne die sind so,
nicht reicht dass das wirklich nicht vorstellen die haben also will dann eben auf dem auf dem auf dem pc gebaut und weiß ich nicht brüten irgendwie im minutentakt irgendwelche milliarden ausnahmsweise irgendwie,
mehr banken besitzen und dann gibt es leute die shoppen gehen in diesem,
in den luxuriöses mals die du dir überhaupt nur vorstellen kannst ihn ins center,
stehen wo so weiß ich nicht ein ein quadratmeter so viel kostet wie halt berlin oder so das ist,
und da sind dann irgendwie so so läden die so groß sind wie das halbe saarland du merkst übertreiben wenig.
Ein bisschen.
Aber auch wirklich nun nur ein bisschen und da sieht man dann zum beispiel so festland millionär s,
kinder rumlaufen die dann irgendwie so träger aus aus indien oder so hinter sich her tragen die einkaufs taschen tragen so ne es muss auch wirklich so ganz,
ekelhaft viel geld unglaublich eklig viel geld läuft darum und direkt davor hast du dann irgendwie.
Carport ladies halten die heißen die nennt man die sind halt alte frauen die offensichtlich keine oder kaum rente bekommen.
Und die farbe so die schieben so ein so ein,
klar zum wagen ladefläche vor sich her wo sie dann kartons,
sammeln also aus den läden raus und was was am straßenraum weil da halt ein paar cent für kriegen,
das hast du halt in in in diesem spektrum habe ich das noch in keiner anderen stadt gesehen also auch nicht in new york city wollen
und dann ja auch irgendwie oder oder oder die branche der einen seite und man ist willig blablabla hipster auf der anderen seite.
Auch ein ganz breites spektrum ist aber das ist alles noch,
das ist das ist quasi noch gemütlich gegen verglichen mit dem spektrum was was was einem in hongkong begegnen kann,
das fand ich gleichzeitig erschreckend und und faszinierend ne es ist also nicht so dass ich das jetzt irgendwie mich in dieser.
Statt verliebt hätte weil weil das alles da so schön ist sondern weil es auf auf auch unglaublich dramatisch ist alles ne.
Was ist denn da also als europäer hat man ja dann auch,
deutschland ist so ein bisschen so dann dieses gerechtigkeit diesen gerechtigkeit schub und was ist denn hier mit der sozialen,
ordnung wenn alles so weit auseinander klappt das hält jetzt sind sozusagen die ganzen millionäre davon ab,
gegen diese ungleichheit zumindest ansatzweise mal vorzugehen oder anders gefragt hat denn quasi dieses
britische regime was ja hongkong auch seine gesetzeslage aufgestellt hat da in irgendeiner form irgendwas
besser gemacht als man das jetzt vielleicht von anderen orten kennen würde wo es diese unterschiede ja auch gibt oder ist es eher egal oder noch schlimmer.
Ich glaube das sind so ein bisschen zwei paar schuhe der wirtschaftliche,
der wirtschaftliche aspekt ist halt wie gesagt gleichzeitig dramatisch und und erschreckend und irgendwie halt auch faszinierend also ich gucke mir das an wie so ein tier forscher fast ne also weil das so fremd artig für für mich ist und ich mir das,
eigentlich alles gar nicht gar nicht vorstellen kann und trotzdem trotzdem ist es so allein die die,
die mieten das ist die morning post ist eine englisch englischsprachiges zeitung.
Mal so ein so ein selbstversuch gemacht und haben versucht eine wohnung auf hong kong island,
zu finden die,
unter zehntausend hongkong dollar im monat kostet sind also ungefähr tausendzweihundert euro und sie haben glaub ich zehn gefunden.
Und haben die dann sind dahin gefahren haben die so fotografiert haben so ein bisschen erzählen was noch ein paar tage.
Und das waren dann so wohnungen irgendwie quasi unter der unter der treppe ne so wie wie harry potter bei seinen eltern gelebt hat.
So ein loch.
Möchte man nicht unbedingt wohnen und das waren so die günstigsten wohnungen wohnungen von hongkong das ist also das entzieht sich jeder vorstellung das ist aber das ist aber eine sache die andere sache ist dann halt auch noch die.
Die politische und dann kommen wir dann auch zu den zu den demonstrationen und.
Hongkong ist ja neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig von den briten,
an die volksrepublik china übergeben worden für die chinesen sagen gerne zurückgegeben worden aber eigentlich ist es ist es übergeben weil,
die briten ja irgendwie diese felsen in hatten und dann irgendwie eine,
damals sechs millionen statt irgendwie da drauf gebaut hatten irgendwie wie kann man ja schlecht zurückgeben,
in dieser während der der britischen kolonial zeit sind sehr viele chinesen nach hongkong,
geflüchtet vor dem vor der kommunistischen partei vor dem bau regime während der kultur revolution,
und viele hongkong sind halt sind halt nachkommen dieser flüchtlinge es ist halt auch eine flüchtlingsrat das ist das macht es auch,
aber das heißt der die sind eigentlich nur ein paar kilometer weit gekommen waren aber dann in einem anderen in einem anderen land,
unter anderem regime oder.
Und es sind auch unpolitische flüchtlinge hingekommen nämlich chinesen die von der ein kind politik die schnauze voll haben die einfach irgendwie 'ne große familie gründen wollten die sind danach,
also mehr oder weniger illegal eingewandert,
und die briten haben das alles geduldet und mitgemacht das halten viele honker denn heute noch zu gute,
und die haben halt auch ein schulsystem eingeführt das heißt auch in den in den sechziger jahren schon als,
auf dem auf dem festland wirklich überhaupt nicht daran zu denken war dass das irgendwie,
bauern kinder von bauern oder so dass sie in die schule gehen kann,
gab es auf hong kong nennen wenn ein schulsystem für alle also einfach so eine volksschule ich weiß nicht wie viele jahre nicht nicht solange natürlich aber so ein so ein basic schulsystem.
Und so hat sich halt eine eine ganz eigene auch,
von von westlich geprägten werten,
von westlichen werten geprägte kultur auf auf dieser,
insel entwickelt also die die auch meinungsfreiheit pressefreiheit versammlungsfreiheit bis heute genießt das sind eigentlich so die drei.
Wichtigsten freiheiten die die die die hongkong der gesellschaft von.
Schon gesellschaften auf der auf dem chinesischen festland und,
da merkt man halt auch wie essen,
grundrechte offenbar sind weil es hat sich halt daraus wirklich wirklich 'ne ganz andere kultur und ein ganz ganz anderes selbstverständnis entwickelt,
wenn man 's jetzt zusammenfassen also bitter kompatibel zusammenfassen wollen würde.
Dann lautet das,
vergiss den ganzen kram mit demokratie und menschenrechte wir sorgen dafür dass es dir das dass es dir gut wirtschaftlich gut geht wir sorgen für wohlstand,
und das ist das funktioniert ist also viele.
Die meisten chinesischen bürger,
sagen das auch genauso sagen irgendwie demokratie brauchen wir nichts da quark irgendwie dann wird nur so 'n trump gewählt oder so alles quatsch brauchen wir nicht,
wir haben lieber irgendwie florierende unternehmen das ist eigentlich uns viel wichtiger und das klappt ganz toll.
Zumindest in den letzten zwanzig dreißig jahren das war natürlich auch nicht unbedingt immer so.
Ja aber das ist jetzt das das ding und.
In hongkong speziell die jugend die halt aufgewachsen ist mit mit einer freien presse mit einem interessierten internet,
und mit versammlungsfreiheit und dem und dem ganzen kam nicht mit einer frei gewählten regierung muss man auch dazu sagen.
Aber die haben jetzt halt ganz große angst dass sie in kürzester zeit.
Halt eingeordnet werden in einfach hongkong ist jetzt eine weitere chinesischen stadt so dazu muss das haben wir jetzt eine erzählung übersprungen neunzehn siebenundneunzig als die.
Als hongkong an china übergeben wurde gab 's halt cremen zwischen per volksrepublik china und großbritannien.
Das hongkong fünfzig jahre lang jetzt dieses system behalten darf.
Und von von china quasi in ruhe gelassen wird dass das war so so der deal und dann schauen wir mal weiter.
Warum hat er überhaupt ok hongkong zurück.
Das war.
Es letztlich war liefen die pacht verträge von den youtube toys aus.
Also diese new territorium.
Hatten.
Genau diese gepachtet haben dass das ist ja dieses große land areal zwischen,
der landshuter colour und der chinesischen grenze das ist gar nicht so dicht besiedelt das sind nur ein paar,
also da ist ganz viel urwald und und land dass ich nicht bebauen lässt und.
Weil es war sehr bergig ist.
Bergig und sumpf ich auch ne also da kannst du halt einfach nicht bauen,
zwischendurch sind dann haben sie immer so ein paar,
plätze gefunden wo man doch prima bauen kann und dann haben sie direkt nach hochhaus siedlung mitten in den urwald gebaut das ist auch ohne eu bahnstation kannst du es einfach hinfahren so ist echt toll.
Und da lief tatsächlich der pacht vertrag aus ne nach neunundneunzig jahren.
Und es wäre tatsächlich rechtlich möglich gewesen einfach die new territorium zurückzugeben heute hätte man quasi eine eine grenze mitten in die stadt bauen müssen also das zu den new territorium gehörte glaube ich auch,
schon irgendwie das ist direkt,
mitten im ring colour oder hatte man quasi so eine berliner mauer bauen müssen und quer durch hongkong,
und da haben sie gesagt so nee quatsch machen wir nicht ne was natürlich möglich gewesen wäre,
wäre das halten das haben die briten auch sonst gemacht,
hongkong die unabhängigkeit zu entlassen sagen so okay,
ihr wart jetzt eine kolonie und das seid ihr jetzt nicht mehr wiedersehen.
Frei ja.
Ihr seid jetzt frei ne viel glück im sohne und irgendwie vertragt euch mit den chinesen sind schwierig,
haben sie nicht gemacht ne und das das wird den briten auch noch vorgeworfen von den hongkong die eigentlich,
sehr gerne unabhängig werden.
Die frage wie lange das gehalten hätte.
Das ist natürlich eine frage aber das weiß man jetzt alles nicht weil die briten halt dass es einmalig eigentlich in der kollegial geschichte,
großbritanniens dass sie eine ehemalige kolonie im anderen land gegeben haben,
wüsste ich jetzt nicht ich stell dir vor den australien an.
Oder indien pakistan oder er.
Oder oder indien an sonst wird.
Also diese new territorial also der,
ich würde sagen wir flächenmäßig größten teil oder
vielleicht größe nutzbar e teil dieses gesamten gebiets was heute zorn konnten gehört das war für neunundneunzig jahre gepachtet das lief aus und die konsequenz war,
okay alles klar wollen sie jetzt damit nicht mehr rum schlagen ist uns irgendwie zu kompliziert nimmt mal aber ihr müsst uns zu sagen dass das system was wir da jetzt aufgebaut haben für fünfzig.
Fünfzig jahre genau.
Fünfzig jahre bleibt was hören und so viel zeit irgendwie auch nicht ist.
Das ist eigentlich auch das ist das nächste einmalige was was auf der welt was eigentlich hongkong.
Auszeichnet dass ein politisches system mit countdown ne das muss man sich mal vorstellen so.
Was wir wie wir die würde sich das leben in deutschland anfühlen wenn die.
Die gründungsphase gesagt haben so wir haben jetzt hier im grundgesetz und demokratie und bla und bundesländer und blut und ne und alles so und verfassung und rechte und so und das gilt fünfzig jahre.
Das würde sich glaube ich ziemlich scheiße anfühlen wenn du einfach weißt irgendwie das.
Das grundgesetz mit verfallsdatum sozusagen mindestens haltbar bis aber vielleicht nicht länger.
Und danach nicht mehr verzehren ne und was danach kommt weiß man nicht ne also man ahnt ist ne.
Und jetzt was was china angeht ist ahnt man ist sehr sehr deutlich ne also die haben halt,
überhaupt kein interesse an einem unabhängigen oder oder möglichst unabhängigen hongkong sondern wollen das möglichst nahtlos ein einreihen in ihr,
in ihren in ihren städten bestand und das war so so in den ersten jahren noch so ein bisschen,
hintergründe ich da wurde so,
also hongkong hat zwei amtssprache nämlich kann tunesischen was was eine sehr eigene form des chinesischen ist also kann nicht nur einfach ein dialekt sondern es ist wirklich eine ganz eigene.
Das eigene sprache und englisch sind die sind die beiden amtssprache und dann wurde von peking seite und von hongkong politikern die,
auf der seite stehen dann schon so dass das mandarina so reingemogelt ne das wird jetzt halt auch eine schulen unterrichtet also die,
die festland variante des chinesischen englisch wird auch immer unwichtig also man merkt auch das so in amtlichen bekannt machen die wurden immer brav zwei sprache ich veröffentlicht dass die jetzt.
Seltener in englisch veröffentlicht werden,
das war so dass das der leichte schwelbrand also gerade über das kan tunesischen haben die versucht.
Einfluss einfluss zu bekommen also das heißt wir wollten eigentlich so ein bisschen die die hongkong kultur,
so ein bisschen marginalisiert ne und das war das führt uns zu zweitausendvierzehn zu dieser.
Am brille revolution der regenschirm revolution die tatsächlich von schülern ausgehen das ist auch ganz interessant ist auch so ein bisschen,
unbekannt wie das eigentlich zustande kam,
das war auch eigentlich so 'ne übergriffig seit der peking zentralregierung,
die ja eigentlich die hongkong regierung mehr oder weniger unter kontrolle haben im griff haben es ist wie gesagt keine keine wirklich frei gewählte regierung.
Bevor bevor du das ausführst also ich denke das nochmal ganz wichtig das zu verstehen also was ist denn jetzt sozusagen,
konkret passiert als diese übergabe stattfand man hat gesagt okay das ist jetzt china,
so aber das system ist anders.
Genau der.
Dann ist es aber zu dieser meine provinz so das heißt,
das ganze rechtssystem ist erstmal offiziell in place gewesen aber was hat china dann konkret getan.
Dann auch mit der zeit zu protesten für ein konto.
Genau das also das ist das zauberwort oder der zauberspruch hieß das heißt die es ist,
alle alle erkennen an das hongkong china gehört,
aber hongkong hat weitgehend autonomie und auch ganz andere freiheiten als gebiete oder andere städte.
Auf dem festland also du kannst zum beispiel nach hongkong auch heute mit einem e u pass ohne visum einreisen und drei monate da bleiben neunzig tage ohne irgendwas china ist es ja wesentlich komplizierter,
und die hongkong haben auch reisefreiheit also es gibt ganz andere.
Gesetzt in ganz anderen gesetzlichen rahmen.
Wird tatsächlich sogar gewählt das ist noch ein anderes gab es sehr kompliziert,
sehr bizarre das wahlsystem aber es ist nicht wirklich demokratisch ne also das ist so viel kann man auf jeden fall sagen über die schule wollten sie zweitausendvierzehn die herzen erobern die peking her,
und zwar mit war geplant ein eine.
Geschichte propaganda fach einzuführen auf hong kong der schulen also so 'ne,
das glorreiche die glorreiche geschichte der volksrepublik china so,
ich weiß nicht zuhörer außer die ddr schule durchlaufen haben die kennen wahrscheinlich solche fächer ne also,
diese.
Bürger kunde.
Genau und wirklich in dieser tradition.
Sowas war sowas war geplant.
Dagegen haben sich tatsächlich die älteren schüler gewehrt haben gesagt den quark wollen wir nicht das fängt so fing die,
wir verlosen an das fängt tatsächlich in den,
in den schulen an und dann haben wir ältere schüler joshua der war damals sechzehn,
solche solche leute haben gesagt so nee das machen wir nicht das wollen wir nicht wir streiken so also wirklich wie jetzt hier,
for future es ging von den von den von den schülern aus und dann haben sich sehr schnell studenten auf auf die gleiche seite gestellt und,
es wurden also dann auch irgendwann kam auch diese die,
bewegung dazu und dann kam es halt zu diesem.
Fast drei monate gegen besetzen des fall des ganzen stadtteils personen der verwaltungs- bezirk.
Von der verwaltung bezirk klingt so harmlos es besteht wirklich nur aus hochhäusern und stadtautobahn.
Und das war ja achtzig tage lang komplett.
Lahmgelegt von von den demonstranten von der april a revolution.
Heißt es weil sie sich gegen tränengas mit regenschirm oder gegen wasserwerfer geschützt haben.
Ja das das das kam das kam später am anfang war es halt also die besetzung begann im,
sommer und dann war halt regenzeit ne dann hat 's halt wirklich.
Saßen die da irgendwie mit den regenschirm und dann kam aber tatsächlich halt diese,
es ist kam dann auch zu tränengas einsetzen und so also es wurde anhalt und so ein symbol für den den aufstand und der führt ja leider zu nichts ne weil es auch,
niemand also ich sag mal es gab keine rolle modell,
also die wussten nicht wo sie hin wollten wir haben dann hat sie haben dann gemerkt so wir können echt die stadt lahmlegen kann irgendwie,
wir kriegen weltweite aufmerksamkeit wir kommen in hier und die tagesschau und alle berichten und.
Interview joshua weil der irgendwie so eine art sprecher sich sich entwickelt hat.
Aber letztlich haben sie dann kein hebel gefunden irgendwie zu sagen wir wollen jetzt jetzt das.
Ja na gut ich meine sie wollten ja vor allem erstmal irgendwas nicht also sie wollten ja vor allem erstmal diese staatsbürgerkunde nicht.
Ja das war dann aber natürlich waren die ansprüche danach sehr viel größer ne und also diese diese komischen unterrichts fächer die die wandern nach ein paar wochen irgendwie war die idee begraben.
Aber.
Erreicht was ihr erreichen.
Natürlich ne genau und nicht genau wie na das ist halt auch immer wenn man sagt ich will demokratie,
einem undemokratischen staat irgendwie also da muss man eigentlich schon ich glaub.
Da muss man wirklich revolution spielen,
dann reicht's nicht irgendwie die stadtautobahn zu besetzen und sich da hin zu setzen.
Das ist eigentlich an dem punkt sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich jetzt fünf jahre später.
Heute seit drei monaten aus recht friedlichen aber großen demonstrationen also bis zu zwei millionen menschen waren ja auf der straße haben gegen dann.
Gesetz protestiert zwei millionen von siebeneinhalb finde ich schon sensationell unglaublich.
Das hat sich ja wird fast drei monate hoch
eskaliert straßen schlachten und zu unglaublichen ausbrüche von polizeiberuf totalitäre was ja alles
beobachten können weil hongkong immer noch ein freies internet hat ne und,
also wenn man auf auf twitter oder oder facebook oder ja meistens eigentlich auf twitter sich diese ganzen videos streams anguckt,
da fällt einem also mir fällt da nicht mehr viel ein.
Was welches nachdenke so angenommen ich wäre jetzt die china.
Ja und mir geht es nur darum ein china so ich meine man,
haben wir noch gar nicht über tai waren,
gesprochen passiert eigentlich auch gar nicht so richtig rein aber auch total waren hat ja china ein ähnliches verhältnis und auch das so eine flüchtlings insel wo vor allem der ganze adel sicher dann sozusagen abgesetzt hat als er kommunismus sich da raum geschaffen hat
hier ist es eben teilweise ähnlich aber nochmal etwas,
andere geschichte jetzt gehört es ja zu china ist also anders als taiwan ist es ja kein unabhängiger staat im prinzip ist es ja jetzt schon machen was sie wollen,
was hältst du denn eigentlich davon ab zu sagen so internet wird jetzt geklappt also was sind die kräfte,
die das verhindern also ist es einfach so dass in diesem arsch von china beeinflussen regierungs system und im ganzen administrative apparat,
die gegend kräfte einfach noch noch stark genug sind dass auch china nicht so kann wie es will oder halten sie sich einfach nur aus taktischen gründen zurück weil sie nicht genug,
weil auch sie noch befürchten zu sehr vom rest der welt in irgendeiner form abgestraft zu werden oder ist das eigentlich egal es gibt nochmal andere gründe warum.
Ich glaube dass das das wäre egal also das ich eigentlich gibt es eine eine seltsame allianz,
die sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht so offiziell so geschlossen hat aber es sind die,
jüngere zwanzigjährige studenten die halt auch letztlich gegen diesen komplett kapitalismus auf der auf der insel,
die komplett kommerzielle regierung von allem auf die straße gehen das ist das schwingt zumindest mit ne also wenn sie das ist das ist zumindest unter so was ja auch klar ist du kannst ja auch irgendwie wie gesagt niemand kann sich da wirklich 'ne wohnung leisten,
und lustigerweise.
Bildet sich da eigentlich 'ne allianz mit genau diesem kapitalistischen system also die die ausländischen,
unternehmen die banken die die broker die ganzen finanzunternehmen die sich da niedergelassen haben und die da fröhlich,
niedrig steuer land und da ist ja quasi eine steueroase genießen die.
Sind natürlich so ein bisschen die die scharren natürlich mit den hufen bei der vorstellung dass sie bald kein freies internet mehr haben oder das meinungsfreiheit und und pressefreiheit ausgehebelt,
oder besser gesagt abgeschafft werden werden könnten die sind dann so die alternative heißen singapur ne,
davor hat glaube ich pickeln ganz große angst dass wenn sie jetzt die daumenschrauben,
zu fest drehen und die menschenrechte zu sehr einschränken dann nehmen diese ganzen banken,
klappen denn ihre rechner zusammen und fliegen nach single,
klappen die rechner wieder auf ne so und dann dann war's das also es gab wohl schon,
so millionär fluchten oder milliardärs fluchten,
hat auch die soulshine morning post berichtet ohne namen zu denn ich weiß auch nicht wer.
Die im laufe der letzten monate werden wohl ihre,
x millionen teuren willen verkauft haben und jetzt einfach nach singapur sind dann gibt's natürlich die angst dass dass die unternehmen hinterher laufen hongkong hat für.
Für peking wirklich nett eine wichtige funktion als als finanzamt hab ich glaube jeder vierte ausland dollar der aus der großen weiten welt nach china reinfließt fließt über hongkong,
das ist das ganz große geldfluss ein einfluss tor sondern das wollen die halt auch behalten,
das ist das ist das dilemma in denen die stecken es ist kein kein moralische des es ist nicht so dass das die führung in peking ich denke wir können jetzt ja nicht nicht schon wieder.
Der den bösen watt,
und panzer da aufrollen lassen irgendwie ist jetzt dreißig jahre her,
massaker und danach waren wir dreißig jahre die männer das ist den mittlerweile egal glaube ich wirklich das ist öfters.
Wo man zu sein ist.
Buhmann zu sein wäre denn vollkommen egal was sie genau wissen,
und die leute kaufen trotzdem unsere iphones die wir hier bauen,
wir sind wir haben den usa das ganze geld geliehen soll nicht mal schön die klappe halten sonst irgendwas wieder haben.
Also so viel selbstvertrauen haben die mittlerweile.
Aber sie zumindest so die wirtschaftsberater der regierung sagen bisher zumindest ist das mein.
Wir machen halt mal mach mal.
Komm mal nicht mit der ganz großen kanone sondern lass uns das irgendwie anders machen,
das ist halt das führte auch so zu diesem super sieben kriegen also es gab ende,
julian den schall,
das eine demonstration auch in einem der außen bezirke den territorium,
die demonstranten auf einmal von so von so verbanden von triathleten überfallen worden mit knüppel nachdem die polizei sich zurückgezogen hatte,
das ist also wirklich minute die new york times hat das minute,
rekonstruiert anhand von handyvideos und das also wirklich festgestellt die polizei ist weggegangen und kurz wenige minuten danach tauchten diese,
leute leute auf alle mit weißen t-shirts und knüppel fing an auf die leute einzubrechen.
Und da waren wir irgendwann wieder weg und dann kam die polizei zurück ne das ist schon ziemlich eindeutig geplant.
Und dass es solche strategien sind halt der versuch ohne panzer das irgendwie durch zu kriegen und und vor der welt dann auch zu behaupten wieso das waren ja anwohner anwohner fühlten sich halt gestört haben demonstranten also.
Das ist schon und jetzt mittlerweile ist es ist so ein so ein punkt erreicht wo ich weiß nicht ob es stimmt aber wo viele demonstranten sagen das ist auch nicht mehr,
hongkong polizei ist sondern das sind das sind bereits truppen von festland.
Die sprechen auch mandarin untereinander wird wird behauptet ich weiß es nicht genau,
aber ich kanns mir vorstellen also ist wenn wenn man sich anguckt wie die.
Wie die auf leute einbrechen die am boden liegen,
ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen dass das die gleichen polizisten sind die da noch vom vom halben jahr.
Eigentlich ganz entspannt mit den mit den demonstranten umgegangen ich war einmal fotografieren da weise zweitausendsechzehn.
Aus einer demonstration wo es eigentlich auch sehr sehr hoch her ging.
Wo dann auch tränengas und und steine flogen.
Und ich hab stand wirklich dicht an dicht mit mit so einer polizei,
mit so polizei blog und hab halt da ich ja sowieso flo bin irgendwie so,
also ja nee ja so ungefähr,
das heißt das heißt eigentlich wörtlich übersetzt,
geist geister mensch wieso so nenne die europäer weil die so eine falle haut haben sehr aus begeistert halten.
Nicht ja dich keine schlechte assoziation ja.
Also dann irgendwie auch quasi als.
Spendest sozusagen.
Was genau das als presse durchgehe.
Deswegen habe ich weiß ich nicht ob ich mir das erlaubt irgendwie da so und die waren halt eigentlich auch sehr,
professionellen die polizisten ne also es war die ganze demonstration war lief sehr für obwohl tränengas und und deine im im spiel waren sehr viel gesiter ab als als hier irgendwie.
Geht zwanzig oder so und auch weil die weil die polizisten eigentlich sehr professionell und sehr zurückhaltend waren und irgendwie nur die straßen und die gebäude gesichert haben und ansonsten sich nicht an provozieren lassen und auch nicht,
von sich aus aggressiv waren das hat mich eigentlich sehr beeindruckt irgendwie also wie.
Wie zivilisiert auch eine demonstration mit,
laufen kann wirklich ne also letztendlich war irgendwie niemand verletzt und,
wenn ich daran denken also ich habe auch wirklich obwohl ich da in der ersten reihe stand wirklich keine angst gehabt vor den ferien polizisten ich habe gedacht die tun mir einfach nichts und die taten ja nix ne standen irgendwie und aber niemand hat geschlagen also.
Also nicht nur dich nicht sondern auch die anderen.
Auch die anderen nicht war immer abstand ne das war schon irgendwie so ein bisschen sowieso ein ritual es würden wir jetzt ganz klar was jetzt kommt und,
dann rückt die polizei vor und die demonstranten rücken zurück und so und dann bleibt man wieder stehen an zehn minuten und guckt sich an und zwar alles.
Also zivilisierte als jetzt in berlin am ersten mai okay.
Auf jeden fall und.
So die britische höflichkeit die dann auf einmal durch schlägt mit stellen sich erst mal an wenn sie irgendwie.
Also die die,
die hongkong der polizei war sehr stolz darauf eine sehr zivilisierte und freundliche polizei sein finest haben die sich genannt ne
es gab also so plakate was irgendwie drauf gepostet haben polizei die form fein ist so wir sind die,
die freund ist ein polizist,
und den eindruck hatte ich auch wirklich ne ich habe wirklich immer so das sind leute die kannst du nach dem weg fragen das ist echt okay aber nein jetzt halt echt nicht mehr und das ist auch da.
Dieselben leute oder ist das jetzt sozusagen.
Ich weiß es halt nicht ne ich weiß es nicht es wird viel erzählt ich ich bin also ich denke schon dass tatsächlich jetzt auch,
truppen polizei truppen oder ob das halt soldaten sind weiß ich nicht vom festland in,
hongkong der pullis uniform,
unterwegs sind wie viele das sind weiß ich nicht ob das nur so irgendwie mal so ein squat.
Keine ahnung aber es ist halt es ist wirklich auffällig dass das.
Also das das überschreitet alle grenzen diese polizei brutalität es geht ja nicht um um irgendwie alle rampen oder um irgendwie mal jemanden schubsen oder so sagen die knüppel,
brutal auf leute auf auf jungen mann teilweise auf kinder ein die am boden liegen die also überhaupt keine gefahr mehr darstellen und sowas hab ich wirklich,
in dieser form noch nie gesehen und das das.
In hongkong nicht gesehen.
Generell noch nicht gesehen also jetzt außer vielleicht hätte,
nein also so in dieser form habe ich da das war noch nicht gesehen.
Ich weiß auch nicht was das mit den hongkong anmacht jetzt ja auf einmal,
auch mit den mit den nicht,
demonstrierenden mit den mit den kleinen bürgern,
die jetzt auf einmal sehen was was für.
Was für eine polizei sie auf einmal haben die jetzt halt ihrer polizei nicht mehr trauen können.
Die jetzt nicht mehr die feinsten sind vielleicht nochmal kurz auch mal darstellen was jetzt eigentlich der grund war das
was unsere regenschirm revolution gewissen sich wieder zurückgekommen ist der auslöser war ja jetzt ein
ein anderer also zumindest in meiner wahrnehmung ging's da vordergründig um ein neues gesetz was verabschiedet werden sollte von der hongkong regierung haben jetzt noch nicht wiederholen gesprochen was
wie diese regierung jetzt eigentlich politisch tatsächlich installiert und aufgehängt ist das wäre vielleicht mal ganz interessant auch nochmal im zusammenhang zu
klären und dieses gesetz hätte im prinzip
die tür aufgemacht zumindest offiziell das eben bei bestimmten verurteilung gesagt werden kann so okay du verrichtet das jetzt mal hier deine strafe in china oder was dort weiter irgendeiner,
über.
Eigentlich schon vorher.
Okay.
Ja ne.
Jetzt schon aus.
Ne ist auch ist auch irgendwie.
Fangen wir fangen wir mal an was ist das eigentlich schon für ein politisches system der ist nämlich auch sehr lustig das ist erstmal das es gibt ein parlament das hat irgendwie ich weiß es jetzt nicht wieviel vierhundert sitze oder so.
Da kann ich jetzt aber volk oder weiß ich jetzt wirklich nicht genau aber auf jeden fall diese diese die sitze im parlament.
Werden zur hälfte nach mehrheit wahl prinzip,
ganz normal gewählt wie wir das auch so kennen mit wahlkreisen und den wahlkreis gewinnt darf dann halt.
Der post wieder so ein okay halt so üblicherweise der fall ist ne okay.
Genau genau und die andere hälfte wird aber von,
lobbyisten direkt bestimmt das ist glaube ich auch einmalig in der welt,
von lobbyisten die sammeln halt nicht in der lobby rum und und quatschen die abgeordneten voll sondern die stellen direkt die abgeordneten.
Wer sind diese leute also ich meine.
Das sind dann ist dann so der hotel und gaststättenverband der it verband und.
Wir reden jetzt wirklich von wirtschaftlichen.
Wird wirtschafts lobbyisten genau wirtschafts-
Bestellen leute in das parlament.
Genau die stellen die haben quasi sitze ne der hotel und gaststättenverband hat dann irgendwie drei sitze.
Ernsthaft das klingeln die untereinander aus irgendwie wäre wäre das dann darf ne wenn dann da rein ist echt war.
Ja in der tat.
Ist einfach auch nur konsequent ne also statt irgendwie das so die leute irgendwie.
Anstatt die politiker zu kaufen schicken sie einfach die leute gleich hin und ihr macht dann einfach die andere hilfe quitt okay sehr interessant realistischer ansatz.
Ja es ist,
und diese diese leute,
wie gesagt für den tourismus verbänden oder von weiß ich nicht von der bauindustrie,
pflanze industrie die sind eigentlich durch die bank peking freundlich ne also das ist deswegen kann man das alles so machen weil die die eigentlich der allergrößte teil von denen ist findet es prima,
mit china geschäfte zu machen ist nicht unbedingt will nicht unbedingt die demokratie fördern.
Hauptsache das geschäft läuft weiter das ist das wichtige.
Und deswegen hat er hat peking da sowieso eigentlich schon das halbe parlament im im griff,
und die andere hälfte die erhalt mehrheitlich gewählt wird das sind dann immer so 'ne handvoll,
demokraten fallen dann hinterher raus ich weiß nicht wie viel da jetzt zwanzig oder fünfundzwanzig demokraten die dann auch aus unterschiedlichsten lagern kommen ne das sind dann auch sozialdemokraten und,
ich glaube auch max ist sitzt da drin und so und diese.
Junge protestbewegung die hat jetzt mit dem christoph,
auch eine eigene partei gegründet versuchen jetzt auch da reinzukommen.
Das sind aber alles einzelne also sind dann quasi symbolische.
Man ist ein symbolisch da vertreten also das ein paar paar abgeordnete darf man was sagen und was im auch mal vom fernseher porter irgendwas gefragt aber eigentlich die gesetzgebung läuft dann läuft an,
und die die eigentliche regierung passiert also die regierungschefin der regierungs von wegen hongkong ist 'ne firma heißt übrigens auch schief executive aus officer,
also die seo von von hongkong ist jetzt halt,
und das und sie ist halt komplett von von peking eingesetzt hat dieses dieses wahlprogramm zip,
also das parlament wählt dann irgendwie den regierungsbezirk,
chef aber eben aus einem aus einem pool von leuten die peking festsetzt ne das ist halt so eine scheindemokratie aus der ddr wahrscheinlich auch kennt ne.
Also es ist halt schon eigentlich abgemacht werden wer das rennen macht.
Und jetzt glaube ich die verhassten personen in hongkong.
Wie konnte es dazu kommen dass das dass das in meine das war doch vor weil das vorher auch schon so mit dieser mit diesem lobbyismus anteil im parlament also das ist jetzt nichts neues was durch die übergabe an china stattgefunden hat.
Doch also das ist das ist das ist quasi das.
Die chinesische variante ne also vorher und unter unter den briten gab es halt auch keine demokratie es ist nicht so dass wir den briten auch,
auf's butterbrot geschmiert ne also es es gab tatsächlich die idee.
Den chinesen quasi ins ins netz ins nest zu legen.
Und in hongkong vor der rückgabe frei wahlen einzuführen der letzte gouverneur auf den namen hatte das tatsächlich vor sein zurück gepfiffen worden von.
Der wollte tatsächlich quasi ein demokratisches hong kong china übergeben weil er genau wusste wenn das.
Das dann schnell unter wandert werden würde.
Dann kriegen wir das halt also wenn man einmal halt wirklich eine demokratie installiert hat ist es schwer die von oben wieder wieder wieder ab zu wirken andererseits.
Es ist in einem in einem system die finale quasi unmöglich und demokratie von von unten zu fordern was jetzt die ganze zeit gemacht hat er hat aber nicht geklappt.
Zetsche hat das.
Das hat es ja also die ihre regierung ich weiß nicht ob sie in persona wird behauptet sie persönlich weiß ich nicht.
Na ja gut ich meine als regierungschefin.
Ja das wird zumindest gewusst haben das ist was was.
Sicherlich immer gesagt haben.
Ja was da passiert.
Das aber dieses wie,
genau jetzt dass das regierung system unter den briten aufgebaut da weiß ich auch nicht,
aber es war auf keinen fall eine demokratie es war ungefähr ähnlich verkackt wie das was jetzt hongkong,
sich sich gebaut hat und der akute auslöser jetzt zu dem zu den demonstrationen war tatsächlich ein,
auslieferung gesetz also es sollte ein gesetz eingeführt werden dass es,
das ist der volksrepublik china ermöglicht die auslieferung von hongkong der bürger zu verlangen.
Und das ist natürlich offiziell war das das war ganz gewichts das hatten sie an angedockt an wirklich so ein sehr.
Schlimmen mordfall wo ein junger hongkong seine freundin umgebracht hat in taiwan nämlich.
Und kam dann zurück also da jemand ich weiß gar nicht ob sie ob sie teilweise lesen oder hongkong weiß ich nicht aber der mörder auf jeden fall.
Hongkong er und er kam dann zurück nach hongkong und teilweise gelassen liefert den aus und da gab's teil waren genau taiwan gilt aber wiederum.
Denn das ist kompliziert aus china.
Also aus der perspektive.
Aus der perspektive.
China also china sich zusammen von außen eingemischt hat gesagt datei waren ja china ist ja.
Ausliefern so und dann wird vermutet hatten.
Dass dieses gesetz lag schon lange in den schubladen und wurde auf genauso ein fall gewartet irgendwie
hat er gesagt so ja würden wir gerne ist ja auch ein ganz schlimmes verbrechen und so natürlich muss der irgendwie ausgeliefert werden aber wir haben über wir können das gar nicht wir haben keine rechtliche hand habe
lass uns doch mal schnell ein gesetz machen,
dass es uns ermöglicht verbrecher an china auszuliefern das war also ganz geblitzt irgendwie an an diesem einzelfall aufgemacht aber es ist natürlich,
ein gesetz gewesen dass es tatsächlich.
Der chinesischen regierung ermöglicht hätte wirklich mit dem finger auf jeden hongkong zu zeigen und zu sagen,
kriegen.
Hier mal in probleme rein.
Gegen den ermitteln wir es gibt da so so grauzone paragraphen so korruption,
geht immer irgendwie kann immer irgendeiner behaupten irgendwie der wollte irgendwie mich bestechen oder so,
gegen den ermitteln wir gegen korruption schickt ihn mal schick dir mal her.
Und das ist als als das so durch sie karte was das für eine was was das für ein mächtiges gesetz ist das quasi,
die wirklich die autonomie komplett untergraben würde und viel da hat sich wirklich die ganze,
bevölkerung von hongkong eigentlich dagegen gestellt also wie gesagt zwei millionen leute sind auf die auf die straße gegangen.
Und so fängt es an also so fing es fing es jetzt an es ging wirklich um die um diese um dieses,
dieses gesetz und hatte natürlich auch alles falsch gemacht was man falsch machen kann zuerst irgendwie gar nicht reagiert dann irgendwie so
ja wir frieren das ein was ist denn was soll das heißt man wird wieder aufgetaut im sommer,
dann drehen wir die heizung anderen ist es wieder auf also das quark ne und,
offenbar war es halt auch so dass das grade unter den unter den jungen hongkong und sowieso drive einfach da war um,
also die da kochte genug vor sich hin.
Ärger zu machen.
Ja um um einfach zu sagen also die forderung wurden dann halt auch größer ne,
also diese fünf forderungen heißen halt irgendwie gesetz werk und lasst unsere leute aus dem frei und,
die vorwürfe der es gibt so diesen vorwurf was hier so ähnlich wie landfriedensbruch wohl wäre,
das soll zurückgenommen werden und als letzter punkt wir wollen demokratie finde ich auch süß eigentlich als fünf fünf punkte reingemogelt ob sie oft auf die liste,
und dass das eskaliert wird dann ja monatelang wirklich vor sich hin und teilweise so dass ich,
das das ist wirklich sehr unglaublich war also die sind ja das war noch recht am anfang ich glaube nach nach drei vier wochen in das parlament eingebrochen eines nachts,
rum randalieren da habe ich auch schon gedacht dass leute geht daraus es ist das ist eine falle.
Weil das irgendwie dass das das fand ich total merkwürdig war wirklich ein steinwurf daneben ist die,
dass das polizeipräsidium also da sind sie alle ne also kannst du hingucken vom parlament und dass sie das halt erlaubt haben war für mich auch so eine art,
weiß ich nicht so so genehmigte eskalation also jetzt zeigen wir mal der.
Die böse demonstrant.
Böse die demonstranten sind die machen unter die,
rein unser parlament von innen an und so jetzt können jetzt kann niemand etwas sagen wenn
tränengas komme also wirkte das auf mich das war auf jeden fall eine ganz bizarre situation die leute da drin zu lassen ganz komisch.
Ansonsten ist dass das interessiert und digital nase natürlich.
Phänomenal finde ich wirklich wie das alles organisiert ist es ist also die geben sich sehr mühe,
eine leader demonstriere revolution zu sein wirklich keine sichtbaren führer zu haben weil sie angst haben die werden verhaftet ne würden dann irgendwie verhaftet und das ist tatsächlich so dass,
das.
Auch auch die die strecken wo wird demonstriert wann wird demonstriert wo treffen wir uns so bleiben wir stehen,
es wird alles in den weltraum über telegram über den über den messenger abgestimmt haben dann so votings die auf einmal aufklappen.
Und da wird live von dem demonstrationszug quasi gevotet bleiben wir hier und bauen für barrikaden,
oder gehen wir was das gehen wir nach hause ne ja kannst du zugucken in echtzeit.
In echtzeit sozusagen eine echtzeit revolution.
Und deswegen ist ja und deswegen halt auch total unberechenbar.
Bitcoin.
Ja und dann ist es gab halt auch so eine auf auf auf google maps basierend der app wo die sich gegenseitig darüber informiert haben wo die polizei sich rumtreibt.
Dieses live wo es jetzt auch so viel stress für apple gab und.
Genau die apple jetzt die genau die apple halt jetzt wo apple den stecker gezogen hat aber die die bauen schon wieder was anderes.
Oder ziehen müssen.
Ja wie auch immer.
Ja und das ist also es ist alles sehr sehr sehr digital sehr social.
Sehr spontan also was was man so vielleicht mops nannte ist da ist da fast in altmodisch gegen,
das finde ich schon alles sehr uns funktioniert weiß sehr sensationell also gerade diesen.
Das ist wirklich,
es wäre eigentlich eine verfilmung wird in dieser nacht in der das waren so hundert zweihundert leute vielleicht in eben dieses parlament eingedrungen sind und auf einmal selber quasi angst vor,
angst hatten wie konnte das passieren also man merkt die so wie die so durch also man sah auf den videos die haben ja also es wurde auch alles live gestreamt.
Wie wie unangenehm den das eigentlich fast selber war auf einmal in diesem fall damit stehen so also.
Einige fing dann anderen für das das das wappen von der wand zu holen und.
Andere haben da irgendwie die wände an ganz weit und andere dachten so ja,
weiß ich jetzt nicht lass uns mal hin und dann kam die irgendwie die ansage der polizei.
Um ich glaube null uhr oder wann das war,
um null der stürm wäre und holt euch raus also das haben sie angesagt dann kommt raus oder wir holen euch raus.
Dann wurde abgestimmt das kannst du auf auf telegram dann wieder wieder angucken also zumindest aus einer abstimmung lief kann kein chinesisch ne oh mann konntest tatsächlich sehen so.
Also bis in diesen kanälen eingebuchtet gewesen und hast du sozusagen verfolgt.
Wobei ich halt wirklich nicht alles verstanden habe alles das meiste auf schnee aber was die englischen splitter konnte ich verstehen.
Auf jeden fall haben wir dann abgestimmt und einige sind so eine handvoll.
Am abgestimmten die abstimmung unter den demonstranten gabel gehen das ist jetzt alles quatsch was soll der quark dann gab's so eine handvoll so fünf sechs leute die haben gesagt nein wir bleiben hier,
quasi wir kennen uns an so sinngemäß ne wir wir lassen uns herausholen wir bleiben hier drin.
Die sind dann tatsächlich in diesem parlamentsarmee geblieben,
während irgendwie die große masse die treppe runter dingens ging und dann gab es bevor die große masse fünfzig leute hab ich will das waren,
das gebäude verlassen haben gab es gab es eine diskussion zweite abstimmung,
mit dem ergebnis dass sie zurück sind und diese diese leute rausgeholt da bleiben wollen mit gewalt herausgeholt haben gesagt haben zusammen,
und das wurde halt auch das konnte man irgendwie mit also auch auf live video auf paris club auf twitter,
verfolgen das war schon ganz ganz dramatisch ne wie gesagt nein.
Krasser ist eine krasse beteiligung das werden wir noch gar nicht klar dass das was irgendwie alles so hoch dynamisch abgeht und,
was er quasi auch erforderlich ist wenn man sagt es gibt jetzt hier nicht irgendein eine gruppe.
Wo wir jetzt mal die entscheidung integrieren die wenn es um schon irgendwie richtig machen weil sie die informationen haben und es läuft irgendwie alles zusammen und wir verlassen uns einfach mal drauf ist ja normalerweise eigentlich immer ist
sondern dass man einfach drauf setzen wir haben irgendwie kanäle und wenn man irgendeine entscheidung entscheidungen brauchen führen wir sie halt herbei indem er dann halt irgendwie voten.
Das führt halt auch dazu.
Online-voting sozusagen hui.
Es es gibt halt eine aber das gibt's ja glaube ich in jeder revolutionären bewegung irgendwie die die frage wie gewalttätig sind wir ne und wieviel,
dieses jahr machen wir unsere stadt kaputt.
Oder halt nicht ne das ist halt auch ein ganz großes ganz großer diskussionen punkt,
natürlich wie auch in jeder bewegung spitze von von leuten die sagen ja wir waren jetzt lange.
Lange genug brav und jetzt die die nehmen wir uns nicht ernst nehmen uns nur ernst wenn wir halt jetzt wirklich mal,
hier die u-bahn stilllegen oder sowas ne.
Das mischt sich dann auch mit mit randalierer,
von denen behauptet wird dass sie eben auch von von von trilliarden oder sogar zivil polizisten
also aus aus aus aus solchen kreisen kommen oder von denen sind.
Die dann irgendwo brand legen oder sondern das ist dann.
Die provokateure die klassischen.
Es sind auch unklar ne also mir ist das dann auch unklar ob das ob das stimmt oder ob das nur behauptet wird also es ist halt das sind halt so diese berühmten grauzone,
was was mich halt wirklich also umtreibt ist,
mir fällt keiner lösung ein wie,
das wie das irgendwie zu einem guten ende kommen könnte mir fehlt da die fantasie ne,
also die chinesische führung weigert sich komplett,
irgendwelche zugeständnisse zu machen oder auch nur zu verhandeln könnte ja sagen so kommen wir setzen uns jetzt mal ok alles hin oder her aber dann wählt man ein so,
dann setzen wir uns mal hinter gucken wir mal reden wir mal miteinander nee das geht absolut nächstes ist in der auf den options zettel nicht drauf ne.
Und deswegen bleibt halt als einzige.
Also weil sie weil sie nur verhandeln wollen wenn es ein wieder gäbe oder weil sie einfach generell.
Weil sie generell nicht verhandeln weil das unter genau weil das ein gesichtsverlust wäre sich mit mit solchen leuten an einen tisch zu setzen dass das findet gar nicht hat ne.
Auch bei zwei millionen leuten von siebeneinhalb millionen.
Auch bei zwei millionen leuten von siebeneinhalb millionen nicht es ist nicht es ist nicht vorgesehen und das ist halt das das ist genau der der dramatische punkte weil die einzige.
Alternative ist es,
eskaliert weiter ne es wird frustration und und größeren zorn auf auf seiten der demonstranten geben die dann noch mehr u-bahn-station anzünden,
und mit dem ergebnis dass die dass die polizei sich legitimiert sieht irgendwie noch willkürliche auf irgendwelche leute
einzubrechen die einen schwarzen hoodie tragen soll und ich mir fehlt die fantasie,
irgendwas.
Was das zu einem guten ende bringt ne wo man also dass man.
Nächstes jahr um die uhrzeit sagen kannst und naja das ist ja nochmal gut gegangen.
Ja ich meine das passt natürlich jetzt nochmal,
müssen wir wahrscheinlich eine größere perspektive aufmachen im detail wenn es dann halt auch bei dieser auseinandersetzung so ja okay wer unterstützt jetzt hier das sensorischen ebene hat apple ein fehler gemacht oder nicht cetera,
und was halt immer sofort zu sehen ist und das haben wir ja im kleinen auch mit diesem aber witzigen sogenannten parlament system das einfach,
der elefant im raum ist halt sehr groß so,
china und china ist jetzt nicht nur für ein problem.
Da ist einfach für die ganze welt ein problem als china ist groß china hat viele leute ein viertel aller menschen wunder,
und sind halt irgendwie,
mehr oder weniger gut arrangiert mit den mit dem status quo kennt sich anders oder sind es keine andere perspektive daraus und man sieht ja auch wie china in der lage ist über lange lange lange zeit solche konflikte auch auszusetzen also,
bit oder auch ihre auseinandersetzung damit den uruguay also im norden chinas richtung mongolei.
Der dauerstreit mit taiwan und ein gewisser hinsicht natürlich auch mit dem rest der welt,
nachdem sie ja immerhin das muss man den erlassen zumindest nicht kriegerisch gegenüberstehen so also anders als die usa machen sie jetzt nicht die ganze zeit über marschieren uns wo ein und,
machen nicht irgendwie alle rund aber so wenn's um ihr eigenes territorium geht da kennen sie irgendwie keinen pardon das sozusagen so ein bisschen das,
was er diesen chinesischen weg deutlich zeichnet und,
mit der wachsenden wirtschaftskraft die china hat und den damit gestiegenen,
einfluss macht sich das ja dann auch immer mehr breit in der welt das heißt man.
Also die weltöffentlichkeit wo wir vielleicht vor dreißig jahren noch gesagt haben.
Ja da dominiert so das westliche system dieser chemie der freiheit und alle alle tollen demokratie die aus allen ritzen raus läuft.
Das hat ja einen relativ schlechten ruf derzeit so und selbst wenn es besseren ruf hätte.
Ist man machtlos ein wenig und sieht so ein bisschen die fälle davon schwimmen.
Was halt komplett kaputt gegangen es ist so dieses dieses wirtschaftsliberale narrativ mit,
generation von so politikwissenschaftler und politik beratern und
wirtschafts handeln die von von konferenz zu konferenz getingelt sind und überall gesagt haben
freie wirtschaft freie wirtschaft freie wirtschaft und im windschatten kommt dann demokratie ne das haben wir überall erlebt,
und nein das stimmt einfach nicht ne also china ist jetzt ein beispiel dafür dass es einfach nicht stimmt,
es ist nein es ist ja auch kein kommunistische es land ist staat kapitalismus,
was was in china praktiziert wird und.
Die versprechen ihren bürgern wohlstand,
und das war's,
und erstaunlicherweise funktioniert das also es ist eben nicht so dass wir diese generation von wirtschaftswissenschaftler oder politikwissenschaftler immer behauptet haben
mit dem wohlstand kommt eine mittelschicht und die mittelschicht möchte dann irgendwie mitreden und deswegen strebt die nach demokratischen,
mitbestimmung option und über kurz oder lang kommt dann ein,
eine demokratie zustande so ging immer die erzählung und china beweist jetzt dass das nicht so ist wenn man mit.
Also ich ich habe mit.
Mit mit leuten von festland also aus dem festland china mit chinesen geredet die wirklich bildet sind die auch im ausland studiert hatten teilweise.
Und die aber fest davon überzeugt sind dass das schon alles okay ist ne also oft also am besten fand ich,
auf die frage ja wie sieht das mit menschenrechten aus deren antwort so.
Ja natürlich haben wir menschenrechte in china die gelten halt nicht für alle.
Eine hundert prozent ernstgemeinte antwort ne.
Ja halt nur für bestimmte menschen.
Für andere halt nicht und kuchen gibt die gilt das dann halt nicht aber sonst haben wir menschenrecht natürlich.
So für chinesen halt.
Genau wir haben ja auch irgendwie meinungsfreiheit ne solange du irgendwie nicht die partei beleidigt und so kannst du deine meinung sagen es ist schon.
Die richtige meinung.
Ja wenn es die richtige meinung ist dann haben wir auch meine freiheit und offenbar scheint das irgendwie für den allergrößten teil,
zu funktionieren und und wenn man jetzt so historisch denkt und pessimistisch wird kann man sagen irgendwie so jetzt warten wir doch mal ab wie lange es dauert bis,
china so als vorbild gilt es wird die ersten aus aus den aus den löchern kriechen und sagen so ja irgendwie das blablabla demokratie war ja ganz nett aber hat auch nur unglück gebracht,
wohlstand ist doch viel wichtiger wir machen's wie die chinesen.
Meine ich freue mich auch immer.
Wie weit das skaliert so meine china ist einerseits halt immer noch in so einer phase gut kenne ich es nicht aber.
Vor dreißig jahren,
befand sich ein extrem großer teil dieses landes der bevölkerung halt ja schlecht in armut und sehr vielen bereichen,
gab's einfach keine nennenswerte wirtschaftliche.
Dadurch dass sie sich eben auf seine rechte kluge art und weise,
an den kapitalismus ran gewagt haben und gesagt haben ja also unternehmerische freiheit da gehen wir jetzt mal mit so macht mal schön und macht mal irgendwie alle unsere verträge aber wir haben halt überall irgendwie auch noch unsere finger mit drin und wir sagen wo es anfängt wo es aufhört
aber ansonsten lassen wir euch machen hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert weil natürlich china da auch aus dem vollen schöpfen konnte mit viel platz,
wir haben viel land wir haben viel,
helfen zugang also unsere schere ausdehnung ist schonmal ein vorteil wir können alles mögliche besiedeln wir haben irgendwie zehn zwanzig dreißig orte wo wir irgendwie millionen städte.
Bauen können wo dann so new york naja okay das war früher mal groß aber heute ist ja eine kleinstadt zum vergleich
plus wir haben so viele leute die quasi für wenig geld bereit sind zu arbeiten wir haben aber trotzdem in unserer chinesischen kultur auch so einen,
doch in erinnern in der gesellschaft dass man sagen kann okay wir,
so läuft es jetzt wir strukturieren weil ihr lernt jetzt mal da so das eben auch innerhalb kürzester zeit so ganze technik kulturen heran gewachsen sind ja was was ich also gerade im norden von hongkong so schön senden et cetera das ist ja so,
ja ist ein anderer.
Schuh.
Schuh genau also es ist eine riesige tech metropole wo einfach,
nahezu jedes iphone gebaut wird und aber nicht nicht nur jetzt dinge zusammengeschraubt werden sollen wo er eine eine mittlerweile extrem weit reichende liefern und produktionsstätte da ist wo man halt,
alles bekommt jede jeder rohstoffe verarbeitet jede zwischen produkte jedes werkzeug und so weiter was,
applizieren das so ein bisschen die die neue kraft man wartet es eigentlich nur so ein bisschen auf diesen moment wo man sagt so okay
jetzt setzen wir auch so die ersten sättigung effekte ein löhne steigen es wird teurer der rest von asien andere orte sind dann in der lage mal wieder zu konkurrieren was,
einfach in den letzten zwanzig jahren so nicht ohne weiteres möglich gewesen ist und dann kommt dann halt einfach auch dieses versprechen ein bisschen ins stottern mit.
Wo bleibt jetzt sozusagen der der zuwachs an an reichtum also lange man diese verbesserung sieht läuft es halt gut aber ist ja noch lange nicht so dass jetzt alle sich schon ins haus und brauchst wählen würden.
Ich ich ahne worauf du hinaus willst ich bin sehr,
skeptisch ob es irgendwie eine wie auch immer geartete,
unruhe bewegung eine breitere in china geben kann allein weil,
die die kommunikation infrastruktur und die presse komplett im händen der zentrale.
Ich wollte es nicht,
ausrufen und und so so und das meine ich gar nicht aber so dieses was du vorhin meint es mit na ja die wirtschaft hat dann auch andere optionen so nach dem motto jetzt wird das hier irgendwie alles ein bisschen so teuer werden
jungs effekte etcetera lass doch mal gucken auch auch andere länder haben schöne inseln und so,
das dann sozusagen auch etwas ist was was was china in gewisser hinsicht
aber es findet wahrscheinlich so einen kleinen skalen maßstab statt dass man.
Also bis bisher also wenn wenn man so durch,
geht und also wo vor dreißig jahren noch so.
Drei fischer orte standen und jetzt ungefähr zehn millionen unser aller iphones bauen oder so,
dann ahnt man irgendwie dass das nicht mal ebenso woanders wieder aufgebaut werden kann und das ist tatsächlich so deren.
Also die beliefern die welt mit hightech,
und das ist machen irgendwie das was was europa vergeigt hat ne also in der beziehung,
ich glaube nicht dass das so dass man das so schnell exportieren kann oder das indien oder auch singapur oder wie auch immer,
in irgendeiner form so schnell diese diese rolle einnehmen kann.
Um nochmal auf hong kong zurückzukommen das auch ganz interessant als hongkong siebenundneunzig an.
China angedockt wurde machte hongkong.
In in diesem jahr fünfzehn prozent des chinesischen bruttosozialprodukt aus das heißt es war eine wahnsinnig reihe,
ein winziger ort verglichen mit dem mit dem riesigen,
reich doktor an war allein unglaublicher reichtum eigentlich den,
china da mehr oder weniger geschenkt bekam mittlerweile sind's glaube ich noch zwei prozent oder so das hat sich in zweiundzwanzig jahren verschoben also das heißt die,
rest china ist ist dermaßen gewachsen dass das jetzt,
hongkong gar nicht mehr so eine so eine große wirtschaftsmacht ist verglichen mit dem mit dem rest das hat auch so ein bisschen,
jetzt zur psychologie zu kommen ein bisschen,
im im fuß volk etwas an der einstellung der festland chinesen zu hongkong.
Geändert und zwar waren das tatsächlich auch bei der,
übergabe an hongkong,
wurde das wurde von dem von dem festland chinesen,
hongkong angesehen wie vom anderen stern ne also das war irgendwie die große offene weite reiche welt na sowas gab's irgendwie,
in china nicht dass das kannte man nicht,
und die sind halt also es war schon so eine art minderwertigkeitskomplexe mit den sich sich viele festland chinesen so hongkong genähert haben,
und mit dem mit dem aufschwung das das festland es hat sich das eigentlich in so einer überheblichkeit,
gewendet na das heißt viele.
Festland chinesen die nach nach hong kong zum shoppen fahren weil das immer noch eine tolle shopping location ist,
bringen eine ganze ecke überheblichkeit mit eine ganze menge arroganz wenn du damit mit mit ihren schwarzen max karten irgendwie durch die mals marschieren,
unter einkaufen das wird von den hong kong dann auch sehr,
gehasst ne also die diese attitüde von den.
Richtige chinesen.
Ja also da da gibt's halt auch so oft auf wirklich auf ich sag jetzt mal so auf auf fußgänger ebene.
Konnten konflikte und und a version irgendwie es ist halt nicht nur in der hohen politik so ja.
Erwartest du jetzt eigentlich nichts anderes als dass dieser zug einfach weiter rollen wird.
Nicht ich also ich erwarte da,
ich erwarte keine einfache lösung und ich weiß nicht wie eine eine nicht einfache lösung aussehen würde ich hab wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung wie sich das,
weitergehen könnte so wie ich die den harten kern der demonstranten einschätze sind sind also sehr viele mittlerweile an dem punkt wo wo sie halt wirklich.
Wo ihnen alles mehr oder weniger egal ist ne also es ist jetzt halt nicht so.
Dass dass sie irgendwann aufhören,
und ich sehe auf der auf der gegenseite,
auf seite der der staatsmacht sich nicht nicht den hauch eines signale alles für gesprächsbereitschaft oder für irgendeine form der.
Konflikt.
Konflikt befreien ich wüsste jetzt einfach nicht wie es weitergeht vielleicht marschiert irgendwann die die volksarmee ein dass das ist so die unwahrscheinliche variante oder so.
Unmöglich ist es auch auszuschließen ist es auch nicht ist es am am hafen also am an der schönsten ecken.
Hongkong gibt es ja schon so eine garnison der der volksarmee die haben sie jetzt auch verdoppelt glaube ich auf zehntausend leute oder so sind da also es ist nicht ohne.
Das ist auch auch möglich aber das würde dann wahrscheinlich auch bedeuten dass das quasi an dem tag irgendwie achtzig prozent der ausländischen firmen irgendwie ihre koffer packen und sich da.
Nach singapur fliegen oder noch sonst wohin taiwan.
Oder.
Oder dubai aber vielleicht ist es dann peking auch irgendwann mal egal ne.
Das prozent kriegen wir schon wieder irgendwie helden komm mal die anderen wieder wohnung frei.
Also dass diese demonstration funktionieren halt auch nur weil es da weil es zum beispiel nach freies internet gibt und freie kommunikation.
Das ist auch was was sofort mal abgeklemmt werden könnte wissen wir alle wie schnell das technisch,
damit wäre auf jeden fall die kommunikation schonmal lahmgelegt und diese,
das system mit dem die sich organisieren.
Ich habe keine ahnung ich habe wirklich keine ahnung wo das hinführt.
Stellt sich natürlich auch noch mal die frage wie man dann so am besten eigentlich mit der ganzen situation,
umgehen sollte jetzt ist er der westen gerade selber nicht so in der allerbesten verfassung extrem auflösung tendenzen eigener bauart
beschäftigt ziehe brexit hier dauerthema sehr natürlich auch die usa wo es wie auch alles völlig gegen die wand läuft
und der rest von europa naja schwächelt halt zumindest macht ja auch vor deutschland nicht halt ich sehe ja solche.
Also bisher war es ja immer so dass es auch mal alles so ein bisschen so sinnlos werde ich daher,
ne also gerade wenn man denkt so oh gott schlimmer kann's jetzt,
jetzt wird noch alles viel schlimmer so oder es geht jetzt nur noch bergab,
so da merkt man dass ein gewisser gewisser hinsicht,
viele dinge dann auch auf seine ganz leise art und weise ohne dass was groß bemerkt hat auch wieder besser geworden sind und dann irgendwann alles wieder mitreißen und dann macht sie auch wieder optimismus breit aber dieses ganze verhältnis zwischen,
china und dem westen sicherlich schon deshalb so interessant so weil es einfach immer alles so.
Momente sind so ja so diese diese diese vision einer einer einer welt in der all die alle nur noch so ein chinesisch englisches misch-masch sprechen ja.
Nur smock herrscht.
Immer nacht ist und es regnet.
Beschäftigt sind replika kanten die wilke freilaufend roboter wesentliche für uns auf dem mars
worauf läuft 's denn eigentlich hinaus auf diesem planeten was ist denn sozusagen irgendwann mal die globale gesellschaft wer gibt denn da den ton an.
Im schlimmsten fall auf jeden fall china das ist also.
Aber bleibt war die anekdote muss ich nochmal loswerden also ich war nur ein tag mal einen schönen und hab mich da um umgesehen und da hab ich tatsächlich gab es da drohnen die,
auf auf cafés auf gastronomische einrichtungen hingewiesen haben also die flogen irgendwie durch die straßen.
Werbung.
Und leucht werbung irgendwie mit dem pfeil irgendwie so,
und da gibt's irgendwie lecker essen so eine drohne,
nein im schlimmsten fall das meinte ich ja gerade im schlimmsten fall.
Wird china irgendwann mit diesem ganzen autoritären system so eine art vorbilder,
weil die die demokratie langsam auch durch durch sowas wie dadurch dass sie unfähig sind sowas wie trump.
Loszuwerden oder denn die brexit foto irgendwie in ihrer,
zurück auf ihre colleges zu schicken.
Dass das narrativ der der demokratie ja so an an glanz dadurch.
Euch geht's gut und eigentlich ist das ja auch so der egoismus der gleiche egoismus denn ja auch irgendwie die.
Weiß ich nicht so leute wie wie wie trump propagieren.
Das das versprechen von trump an seine wähler ist ja.
Du darfst arschloch bleiben,
so die ganzen linken und die gutmenschen und so die sagen irgendwie du das soll es ein kleines auto fahren und deine frau nicht schlagen und irgendwie
und du darfst irgendwie keine bösen sachen auf schwarze menschen sagen und zwar die wollen ja irgendwie und ich sag dir du darfst das alles du bist du darfst ein arschloch bleiben soll,
irgendwie ist das auch so oft auf einer anderen ebene kommt das auch aus aus peking,
so das wichtigste ist wirtschaft und danach eigentlich ist alles andere egal ist nicht das wichtigste das einzig wichtige so und,
na und dann fährst du ein bisschen auto aus einer wohnung und,
alles prima wenn.
Freilos freitag für hubraum sozusagen ja.
Genau und das ist das ist ja genauso arsch noch ich sein eigentlich ne das war das ist auch wenn sie sich jetzt so ein bisschen green fashion da in china das ist.
Hab ich das erste mal und so diese beschreibung genauso wie das sagst du dieses so trump ist so.
Die leute wollen so sein wie er ja erst ein arschloch ich will ja auch ein arschloch sein und ich will ja auch irgendwie rumoren und will irgendwie goldenes klo und den ganzen schlechten geschmack und so sicher auch haben.
Das erste mal dass ich eine erklärung für so einen europäischen führer gehört habe genauso das war berlusconi,
ja der auch wo ich mich auch mit italienern unterhalten warum wie kann es sein dass du weißt du so man ist ja so als.
Wir alles.
Bildet haben menschen mit illusion ist man ja immer so fassungslos,
die wollen alle so sein wie er und deswegen,
wen sehen einfach.
Ja ganz genau.
Warum wollen denn die leute nicht so sein wie viel mario viel zu verkauft.
Ach guck guck mal auf mein konto dann ist das es mag eine antwort sein.
Das ist in der tat ein argument ja.
Ja weiß ich auch nicht ja.
Tolle ab gesang wo was machen wir denn jetzt jetzt müssen wir auch noch irgendwie zum podcast,
positiven ausblick wo alle dann wieder hoffnung.
Ist das so ja dann.
Ja was sagt das navi sagt das narrativ hast du gerade nicht am start.
Ich hab also dafür haben wir jetzt zu viel über.
Ne ernsthaft also es ist vielleicht dreht sich alles alles wieder ins gute irgendwie das ist ja auch,
vielleicht ist auch mit vielleicht war trump auch der der höhepunkt der arschloch wählen also es ist jetzt es scheint ja auch so das ist natürlich jetzt nach der thüringen war ein bisschen schwierig das anzunehmen,
aber es scheint ja zumindest ein bisschen gedeckelt zu sein also die die ganzen lebens und die ganzen wilders und so die kommen ja über eine so eine gewisse prozent,
würde auch nicht hinweg und die afd im westen ist ja.
Auch irgendwo bei zehn zwölf prozent und zeit hat.
So brexit und trump vielleicht ist das jetzt so so arschloch arschloch wählt.
Und in ein paar jahren haben wir irgendwie ganz neue frische in der in der demokratie zum beispiel durch irgendwie so.
Die leute von von for future oder so was ich echt toll finde.
Ich möchte das jetzt mal nicht ausschließen.
Und in dem zusammenhang.
Ich bin ja auch so ein bisschen so generation digital optimist,
und erinnere mich selber noch sehr gut ich hab im chaos radio irgendwann mal eine sendung tatsächlich unter dem.
Titel twitter demokratie geführt und es war dann so zu den zeiten der der revolution da in,
tunesien wie sie noch gleich wie nennt man sich doch gleich die.
Die täter revolution.
Ne es gab da noch so für diese arabische frühling.
Arabische frühling genau das machen.
Der dann nicht so gutes wetter hatte der frühling wie man,
so dachte und.
Und.
Ich muss mir vielleicht die sendung auseinander anhören aber es war auf jeden fall auch so ein bisschen getragen von auch so da,
überzeugung die wir sagen wir mal generation früh internet so gehabt haben mit na ja
wenn dann die welt erstmal miteinander in kommunikation tritt und das geht ja jetzt alles so schön mit dem internet und wir alle irgendwie mal miteinander reden,
die erfahrung macht man ja wenn man dann erstmal miteinander redet so dann dann fühlt man sich dann auch irgendwie eigentlich wir kennen uns ja alle noch gar nicht so richtig mit der noch gar nicht vorgestellt worden aber wenn die welt dann irgendwie an,
großen dieser großen bühne zusammenkommen und sich dann trifft dann dann wird alles gut,
zum teil erwartung und vielleicht ist das ja auch so andererseits aber jetzt erstmal gemacht so jetzt jetzt kommt ja irgendwie alle zusammen und alle schreien sie die ganze zeit nur an hassen sich und irgendwie nur daran interessiert sich bestätigt zu sehen in ihren vorurteilen und
hauen sich irgendwie gegenseitig um machen sich runter und alle vorteile werden sozusagen nochmal verstärkt.
Ja das hatte ich ja auch tatsächlich auch nicht offen sein ich habe ja auch gedacht als was irgendwie mit der blogger rei anfängen und mit social media soll so langsam und,
irgendwo brecht radio theorie und jeder ist ein sender und
die massenmedien sind ein phänomen des zwanzigsten jahrhundert und so und alles toll und alle reden miteinander
wir wir erklären jetzt ganz ganz schnell neue neue niveaus der,
der der erkenntnisse.
Und naja und jetzt haben wir erhalten,
us-präsidenten mit dem eko eines achtjährigen der täglich twittert.
Und wir haben äh rassistische mörder die übers internet irgendwie ihre ihre tat per video livestream sonne das hatten wir damals nicht auf dem zettel,
ernsthaft ich das habe ich auch nicht offen soviel lag hätte ich damals nicht saufen können um mir das irgendwie als historie ausmalen zu können,
was nicht heißt dass ich jetzt irgendwie komplett des illusionen wert bin.
Aber doch mit meinem optimismus jetzt ein bisschen dosieren umgehe.
Ja also wer da wahrscheinlich auch auf dem gleichen level,
es heißt ja auch nicht dass man vielleicht ist es auch so ein bisschen sonne sonne.
Selbstüberschätzung auch eine intellektuellen gruppe die ja sozusagen dann immer auch alles durch denkt und dann war davon ausgeht so riesending und,
ja das logische schlüssel dass das alles irgendwie eine rolle spielt spielt auch eine rolle aber dann eben einfach auch,
immer nur wieder in diesen kleinen eliten die einfach aus ihren,
zehn bis fünfzehn prozent gesellschafts anteil auch nicht nennenswert rauskommt man dem daraus nicht automatisch schließen kann das andere auch andererseits haben wir eben auch vorstellen dass wir schon auch nochmal so einen backlash bekommen weil,
irgendwann.
Man ist ja jetzt nicht so dass das jetzt besonders toll wäre so und irgendwann setzen ja dann auch so sättigung effekte ein seid dann sagen so.
Okay jetzt haben wir uns irgendwie,
jahrelang geschrien an alle leiden vielleicht lernen wir ja was da draußen also das sozusagen diese,
weiterentwicklung einer globalen gesellschaft,
schlicht mehr zeit braucht und dass wir vielleicht mal in skalen von dekadent gedacht haben,
auch nur in jahren aber jetzt sehen müssen so ne ist ja,
ist vielleicht eben etwas wo größere schritte also mehrere generationen ja in zwanzig dreißig jahre schritten voran gehen müssen bis diese effekte auch tatsächlich eine auswirkung haben gibt.
Ja das ist das wahrscheinlich der richtige ansatz wenn man sich mal anguckt wie lange es vom vom buchdruck,
bis zur aufklärung gedauert hat also der,
also die aufklärung wäre ja einerseits ohne buchdruck nicht möglich gewesen andererseits hat hat der buchdruck erstmal 'ne ganze menge quark produziert,
bevor dann irgendwie sowas sowas greifbares herauskam und da ist vermutlich haben wir das alles so ein bisschen gedanklich abgekürzt,
also auf einmal alles so auftaucht und und alles so toll war.
Und ja das war dann unsere unser unser über mut.
Das war unser übermorgen ich hab schon öfter in anderen podcast zitiert für das projekt immer wieder ganz schön das world in data aus von,
deutscher in oxford so nebenbei macht und immer wieder so studien zusammen trägt und,
auf dinge schaut wie die welt sich so entwickelt hat über extrem große skalen räume also was auch immer studien zu zahlen hergeben und wie lange sich überhaupt ein bestimmter effekt so.
Habe ich auch erwähnt in meinem buch habe ich schon erwähnt dass das buch heißt warum an die zukunft denken und im duden verlag erschien.
Hast du schon ja.
Und da habe ich auch diesen aspekt irgendwie so zufällig also da habe ich auch erwähnt.
Hast du mit reingebracht genau,
wo er im wesentlichen wenn man mal die klima den klimawandel problematik also die umweltprobleme warte mal,
rein die gesellschaftlichen faktoren schon sagen so eigentlich ist alles immer besser geworden.
Das infos das interessante ist dass man sofort gegenwind kriegt wenn man das wenn man das sagt weil man sofort klingt wie jemand der den status quo bewahren will auch wenn man das gar nicht will,
das ist ein ganz ganz lustiges gegen gegen phänomen weil es ist ja tatsächlich alles also vieles nicht alles aber es ist tatsächlich vieles immer besser geworden weil.
Viel gekämpft wurde.
Also in die gesellschaft sind besser geworden weil weil die rechte erkämpft worden die sind eigentlich nie irgendwie so von von alleine gekommen.
Und.
Das ist eigentlich diese diese erkenntnis ja,
in vielen bereichen wird vieles besser ist eigentlich eine bestätigung.
Dass es das sinnvoll ist sich sich zu bemühen und zu kämpfen und die politik zu nerven und zu demonstrieren und auf die straße zu gehen und,
laut zu sein und zu twittern und faschistische arschlöcher faschistische arschlöcher zu nennen und nicht irgendwie rechtspopulisten so weil man kann etwas erreichen.
Jetzt hast du noch geschafft den positiven abgang zu formulieren.
Sehr schön.
Mario vielen dank das war interessanter einblick wenn man mal schauen wie sich das so
weiterentwickelt bis jetzt erst nachgang aufgegangen dass ich ja dann sozusagen vom vom vom brexit zu hong kong der weg ja gar nicht so weit ist weil es ja dann auch wieder so eine britische un art ist die sich hier breit macht
mal schauen lassen sich ja sicherlich noch ein paar andere interessante,
vorgänge offenen irgendwie was mit briten zu tun haben
aber mir geht's ja gar nicht in britannien sondern einfach nochmal so gucken,
wohin die reise so geht auf unserer kleinen welt deswegen heißt das ja hier auch.
Kaffee also vielen dank nochmal vielen dank fürs zuhören.
Die fünfte und irgendwann gibt's dann auch die nächste.